las consecuencias de la guerra en
Ucrania no solo tienen un efecto en
Europa también lo tienen en el resto del
mundo según la alianza el secretario
general de la otanberg ha advertido de
que si Vladimir Putin gana la guerra en
Ucrania esto puede enviar un peligroso
mensaje hacia otras dictaduras y hacia
otros países en el mundo que quieran
copiar el mismo modelo un claro aviso
también a China que cada vez tiene una
política más agresiva hacia Taiwán pero
también con una relación cada vez más
amenazante y más asertiva hacia la zona
del Indo Pacífico asegura la alianza
precisamente los ministros de exteriores
de la otan se han reunido con sus
homólogos de Japón Corea del Sur Nueva
Zelanda y Australia para abordar la
situación en la zona de endopacífico
especialmente en las amenazas por parte
de China el país además preocupa porque
cada vez está más cercano a Rusia tiene
cada vez una cooperación más estrecha
además ha evitado condenar la invasión
por parte de Rusia cooperan
estrechamente en materia económica y
además también tienen actividades
conjuntas en la zona del Pacífico Y
aunque china no ha apoyado militarmente
a Rusia preocupa mucho a la alianza que
lo lleve a hacer el secretario general
de la otan ha advertido de que si china
ayuda finalmente a Rusia sería un error
histórico con graves y severas
consecuencias en la reunión de ministros
de exteriores de hoy ha participado como
miembro pleno Finlandia aún así la
organización Espera que pronto también
Suecia se pueda unir